[Musique]
bonjour Julien bonjour Pauline le
gouvernement borne annoncera tout à
l'heure à un plan d'économie d'énergie
globale pour réduire la consommation de
gaz et d'électricité et la presse en
présence déjà les grandes lignes avec
cette question Pauline qui s'affiche à
la Une de Libération somme nous prêts
pour la sobriété vous allez le voir sur
cette jolie photo avec un très joli col
roulé qui pourrait à l'empereur un
certain nombre du gouvernement qui
pourrait bien devenir notre compagnon
des prochains mois donc ce seront 50
mesures qui vont être présentées tout à
l'heure chiffrées qui pourraient
permettre nous dit-on de réduire d'au
moins 10% la consommation énergétique
globale du pays sur les deux prochaines
années cela concerne surtout les
entreprises privées publiques les
transports et vient ensuite la délicate
question du chauffage on entend depuis
quelques semaines déjà avec le Conseil
voir l'impératif de course de chauffer
en moyenne sur logement à 19 degrés oui
mais nous dit libération comment faire
si vous habitez une passoire thermique
on nous dit passez par les égards
dans les grandes villes prenez cet
exemple justement dans les Yvelines en
région parisienne tout près de Paris
avec 16 gouvernementales qui ne
suffisent pas toujours à rénover des
donc de ce qu'on appelle des passoires
thermiques nous sommes à Trappes et dans
les Yvelines dans certaines copropriétés
les travaux sont tels que même avec des
aides gouvernementales nous dit-on et
bien les travaux sont impossibles à
financer pour des populations qui ont
déjà du mal à finir les fins de mois
pour le maire de la ville vu l'urgence
de la situation les économies d'énergie
peuvent être faites ailleurs notamment
sur les éclairages publics ou encore sur
le chauffage entreprise privée au risque
de fragiliser il disait une population
qui a déjà du mal à finir les fins de
moi quelles sont les autres pistes qui
sont envisagées et bien l'une d'elles
c'est le transport avec notamment des
bonus pour ceux qui voudraient faire du
covoiturage pour se rendre sur leur lieu
de travail ou alors et bien ce serait
tout simplement le retour du bon vieux
télétravail qu'on a connu durant la
pandémie sauf que nous dit Le Parisien
travailler à la maison il fait du
chauffage c'est bien mais encore faut-il
qu'il y ait du chauffage vous le voyez
sur ce plan d'économie l'équation reste
difficile à résoudre on parle là
d'économie d'énergie mais aussi de
limiter au mieux les factures des
Français et si la solution Pauline tout
simplement de remettre à plat le marché
européen de l'électricité bien pour Le
Figaro le problème c'est que ce marché
de l'électricité est indexée sur le prix
du gaz et pour la 1 pays comme la France
c'est ubues que je cite pourquoi parce
que ce prix de l'électricité en fait ce
système en fait d'après Le Figaro est
hérité de l'Allemagne qui préfère
utiliser ce système parce que ça
c'est plus avantageux pour l'Allemagne
sauf que pour un pays nucléarisé comme
la France la France ne devrait pas avoir
un soutenir un tel système encore
faut-il que ces réacteurs nucléaires
fonctionnent totalement et puisqu'on
parle de nucléaire les menaces se
brandit par Vladimir Poutine
d'utilisable l'arme nucléaire font
couler beaucoup d'encre oui la mérite
perd du terrain en Ukraine on en parle
beaucoup sur nos antennes et Moscou
élève son niveau d’alerte nucléaire le
Times britannique avait publié en début
de semaine un article très détaillé sur
les manœuvres militaires en cours de la
Russie avec vous le voyez juste à droite
ici ce train militaire lié à la
dissuasion nucléaire russe qui aurait
été photographiée dans le centre de la
Russie tous là pourquoi et bien pour
faire pression sur l'Occident le temps
prend l'affaire très au sérieux vous
allez voir le dessin de presse derrière
le prend un peu moins pour illustrer ces
nouvelles tensions le dessinateur
Patrick blower a choisi de représenter
un Vladimir Poutine très viril torse nu
sur un missile nucléaire c'est le
détournement après le cheval d'une
célèbre photo où le président russe
affiché effectivement sur un cheval dans
les steps de Sibérie et tout cela se
déroule dans un contexte tendu pour le
président russe effectivement 7 mois
après le début de la guerre en Ukraine
et surtout après les récentes des routes
militaires de l'imam et de rerson des
voix dissonantes se font de plus en plus
entendre en Russie et non à l'extérieur
de la Russie c'est ce que raconte le
gardien je cite les nouvelles sont
mauvaises la fatigue s'est installée et
il n'y a pas assez de troupes pour
conserver les territoires gagnés ça
c'est le témoignage d'un journaliste
procremlin même chose à la télévision
russe d'état ou certaines lois
s'étonnent et accuse le gouvernement de
mentir lorsqu'il évoque je cite des
retraites tactiques au lieu de
reconnaître une défaite militaire on en
revient à la France et en France avec ce
sujet brûlant pour la culture celle ce
sujet de l'avenir de nos cinémas
regardez cette image est-ce que ce sera
une image d'histoire dans quelques temps
ou est-ce que ça sera notre avenir la
croix se pose très sérieusement la
question depuis la fin de la pandémie la
fréquentation des salles françaises est
en baisse depuis le début de l'année
2022 on a un peu plus de 100 millions
d'entrée à titre comparaison 2019 à la
fin de l'année 2019 c'était un peu plus
de 213 millions donc cette année on y
sera pas ça c'est sûr la croix nous pose
cette question du coup est-ce que c'est
la dernière séance pour les Français
est-ce que les Français ont abandonné le
cinéma la réponse évidemment et non mais
il y a des états généraux qui sont
demandés par les professionnels du
secteur la pandémie a certes bouleversé
les habitudes avec notamment les
stratégies très agressives des
plateformes de streaming le gouvernement
va donc lancer une campagne destinée à
refaire du cinéma je cite une expérience
unique car le cinéma nous dit-on c'est
une image vue en grand dans le noir
comme un vrai tableau par rapport à sa
carte postale tout est différent a
commencé par les émotions ressenties
dans une salle de cinéma mais si le
problème pauline est bien c'était le
prix de cette place de cinéma
s'interroge Sud-Ouest le prix moyen sur
à l'échelle du pays c'est 7 euros mais
là on ne parle pas des prix de ticket
dans les dans les grands complexes
peut-être faudrait-il moduler le prix en
fonction du jour de l'horaire ou voir
même du type de film regarde et donc de
la technologie utilisée mais
malheureusement cette idée ne plaît pas
vraiment au professionnel du secteur
comme c'est étrange merci beaucoup
Julien pour cette revue de presse